[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi à 8
mars et nous débuterons avec une légende
de la photographie française robert
doisneau ses filles ont imaginé une
exposition autour d'une période peu
connue de sa carrière ses clichés
mondain pour le magazine vogue et du
côté du théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est un voyage
musical qui est proposé le quatuor ardeo
propose une balade dans le temps
philippe thuillier musiciens emmanuel
burdeau artiste peintre le temps d'une
journée ils se sont associés pour une
performance une oeuvre unique
il est l'un des plus célèbres
photographes français robert doisneau et
celui qui arrive réaliser le fameux
baiser de l'hôtel de ville en 1950 il
aimait capturé à travers son objectif
les villes leur vie et leurs habitants
le photographe français c'était en 1994
en laissant derrière lui quatre cent
cinquante mille négatif à versailles une
exposition imaginée par ses deux filles
s'intéressent à une partie peu connue de
sa carrière ses trois années comme
reporter mondain pour le magazine vogue
camille lambert et patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
oui
non
des clichés méconnu réalisé par une
légende
robert doisneau dans un univers qu'on ne
les connais pas c'était d'abord des 41 à
52 ans signe un contrat avec le journal
drogue
on lui demandait de faire des sujets sur
la vie mondaine à paris où vous élargir
un peu le sujet mais c'était surtout à
cette époque les mariages chimiques dans
la vie mondaine de somptueux bal et
mariage en noir et blanc représentant un
monde que robert doisneau ne maîtrisait
pas toujours on est dans l'après guerre
c'est à dire qu'à une reprise de la vie
culturelle formidable en france et des
jeunes artistes qui s'appelle bernard
buffet jeunes moreau qui est à la
comédie française michel galabru qui
vient de sortir du conservatoire et
voilà et on lui demande d'aller
photographier tout ce tous ces gens là
et il est très heureux de le faire parce
que ils se sont très bien en compagnie
des artistes peut-être mieux en
compagnie des duchesses et de comtesses
qui marient leurs enfants 73
photographie minutieusement choisis
parmi 450 mille clichés
à 23 ans après sa disparition
robert-doisneau nous dévoile encore de
nouvelles facettes de son talent
pour les passionnés de photographie la
ville de versailles lance un concours le
thème et si doisneau photographier
versailles aujourd'hui le concours est
ouvert à tous jusqu'au 7 avril prochain
les 40 meilleurs clichés seront exposés
à la galerie de l'école des beaux arts
de versailles et pour s'inscrire
direction le site internet de la commune
au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines quatuor à
cordes exclusivement féminin propose une
balade dans le temps des grandes figures
du classicisme viennois aux compositeurs
contemporains
elles joueront la semaine prochaine
différentes oeuvres de la musique
classique un sujet dan leur langue et
des gongs des harmonicas à verre et des
blocs
bienvenue dans l'univers insolite et
captivant du quatuor ardeo en résidence
au théâtre de saint quentin les quatre
jeunes femmes reviennent le 14 mars
prochain pour un troisième concert quand
le théâtre nous a offert de venir
proposée
3 concerne on s'est dit qu'on allait
construire une programmation pour faire
découvrir aux temps des oeuvres connues
du répertoire classique que des oeuvres
tout à fait hors normes qui sont pas
forcément
connu du grand public ou pas encore
connus du grand public
l'occasion pour le public de découvrir
trois grands compositeurs classiques
legrand beethoven plus connu pour ses
symphonies et dont on découvre ici le
talent pour la musique de chambre
le romantique schumann et enfin l'oeuvre
contemporaine de l'ukrainien valentin
s'il veut strophes ont fait mon pas
autant la distinction entre mi classique
musique contemporaine et dont on
pourrait être surpris
on pourrait jouer huit mesures des
derniers quatuors de beethoven on
croirait que c'est des musiques
contemporaines et inversement
donc je pense qu'il faut dépasser
c'était
ah ça a été écrit aujourd'hui à ça va
être ça va être bizarre était écrit il
ya longtemps il fallait plus facile mais
il y a quinze ans à la suite d'une
rencontre au conservatoire de paris
le quatuor ardeo fait partie des
formations remarquer est récompensé de
la scène classique
carole joël yuko et mis ça ne se lasse
pas de travailler ensemble
leur ambition partagée encore de
nombreuses années leur passion commune
pour l'univers classique d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui
il faut venir goûter la musique
classique en live parce que les gens
sont très surpris souvent ils disent ah
mais en fait c'est vivant oui parce que
nous on est artiste vivant
ce week-end se tenait la première
édition du festival électro chic trois
jours de concerts sur versailles grand
parc avec des groupes du monde électro
en devenir c'était aussi un moyen de
réaffirmer l'importance de la cité
royale dans le monde électro deux des
plus grands groupes sont versailles et
on ne les présente plus air et daft punk
alors il y avait des concerts mais aussi
des performances des rencontres entre
artistes de différentes disciplines
philippe thuillier et membre du groupe
saint michel emmanuel brodeau lui est
artiste peintre
leur point commun ils sont versés y est
nicolas d'enlever pour les images
une respiration deux artistes qui
s'associent les musiciens l'autre
peintre leur projet anima souffle en
latin nos sources d'inspiration c'est
beaucoup les choses beaucoup de choses
comme on dit on sait strahl antique les
peuples d'origine ça peut être les
natifs les indiens natifs d'amérique ça
pète
il ya un truc sur lequel on se retrouve
vachement on appelle ça des danses
indiennes et c'est quand manu faire des
passes et des personnages qui sont en
train de danser avec quelque chose de
chamanique de tribal de spirituel de
l'impression d'être deux petits sagouin
qui parle des racines de l'humanité des
tribus de ces choses là alors qu'on
connaît pas ça dans nos vies mais on a
l'impression que ça résonne
une page blanche pour emmanuel brodeau
un micro et un ordinateur pour philippe
thuillier
leur performance est une oeuvre unique
créée autour d'un maître mot
l'improvisation
une fois que le départ est lancé après
ça s'arrête plus on sait on sait pas où
on va mais par contre je sais maintenant
on sait ce qui se passe maintenant et
cette peinture et là des allers retours
des courbes et philippe avec la musique
une vibration on essaye de connecter 7 7
7 vibrations de la musique et de la
peinture en même temps c'est l'heure
pour dire la même chose des coulures de
peinture qui dansent sur la feuille au
rythme de la musique des visages qui se
forment un instant suspendu
[Musique]
eux aussi baigne dans le style électro
les six musiciens du cabaret
contemporain mêle instruments
acoustiques aux objets hétéroclites
ils seront sur la scène nationale les 10
et 11 mars prochains regardez cet
extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 19e printemps des poètes se déroule
en ce moment le thème de cette nouvelle
édition l'afrique ou plutôt les afriques
jusqu'au 25 mars tout le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines vivra au
rythme des rencontres des lectures ou
encore des expositions est l'invité
d'honneur de cette année c'est samira
negrouche l'écrivaine et poètes
francophones alain algérienne elle était
l'invitée de voûte friedrich y le jeudi
2 mars regarder un continent qui est
très souvent soit oublié soit
stigmatisée on oublie que c'est quand
même la mère des civilisations notre
berceau à tous que ce soit génétiquement
au culturellement un continent qui peut
être une pour une certaine partie de son
histoire s'est transmis de façon orale
mais qui comporte aussi d écriture
singulière très forte très diverses
qu'elle soit francophone comme venait de
le dire jacques fournier mais également
l'uso phone anglophone est également
dans des langues qui sont très anciennes
parmi lesquels je citerai le tamazight
puisque je suis nord africaine samira en
plus c'est une grande voyageuse
c'est à dire que ça ça en écriture se
nourrit de tout ce qu'elle voit c'est
une éponge et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
aussi dans son dans la personne qu'elle
est que je connais depuis maintenant
quelques années puisque ça m'ira voilà à
participer aux manifestations de la
maison de la poésie
dans une autre époque et je vais
proposer de revenir cette année d'être
l'invité d'honneur de ce printemps des
poètes sur 3,3 de semaine et sera
présente jusqu'au jusqu'au 18 mars la
dernière vainement dans lequel elle
interviendra et son écriture moi m'a
intéressé par ce que il m'intéresse
toujours parce que justement elle elle
cherche on a l'impression que dans son
écriture elle est en train de rien et
rien n'est définitif il ya une recherche
les formes ne sont pas toujours les
mêmes d'un ensemble politique à l'autre
cette semaine nous partons aussi les
sept d'elancourt le coup de coeur c'est
celui des luttes beaucamp alors le coup
de coeur du 6 décès de cette semaine il
y en a deux mais je vais parler
principalement du premier film de
nicolas bedos qui s'appelle monsieur
madame adelman qui sont aujourd'hui dans
nos salles
c'est un premier film très réussi je
sais que nicolas bedos est comme ça pour
la sortie de son premier film il a
beaucoup travaillé dessus c'est une
collaboration evoria thiviers avec qui
il a travaillé sur canal+ que ceux qui
regardaient canal+ il ya quelques années
maintenant et c'est savoureuse histoire
d'un couple pendant 45 ans de leur vie
commune de leur rencontre je dirais à
l'heure à leur âge mûr c'est très
savoureux c'est aussi très belle
histoire d'amour c'est drôle c'est
romantique donc c'est vraiment à voir
c'est une preuve
un premier film je leur précise et puis
un petit coup de coeur deuxième pour le
film de lucas belvaux
on est en hausse mais lucas belvaux
aussi de cette séance très particulier
venez voir aussi chez nous dans nos
salles qui est une comédie on va dire
dramatiques sur la river et la montée du
front national dans un petit village du
nord de la france
c'est un excellent amuse beaucoup de ces
rares cas étaient surveillés
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous à ne pas manquer le groupe théâtral
unionistes joue sur six dates un
classique de la comédie italienne
l'éventail de goldoni une pièce à
costumes ou la chute d'un simple
éventail va provoquer de nombreux et
quiproquos et je vous l'annonçais la
semaine dernière des places sont en jeu
pour le concert de hugh coltman
si vous souhaitez y assister direction
la page facebook de tv fil 78 et voilà
le 7 une culture est maintenant terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis et
je vais à mercredi prochain
[Musique]